[Musique]
mylène farmer
sur les routes de france et c'est fait
je prépare à l'humain passe de radio
sans vous entendent envoyer des petites
filles qui comptait 1 maman à temps
racontez moi un petit peu vous avez
grandi au québec au canada
oui j'ai vécu à montréal pendant près de
10 ans mais vous êtes française je suis
française et canadienne jill est de
nationalité
et puis je suis arrivé à paris et depuis
j'ai vu alors vous avez fait quoi vous
avez vous été mannequin je crois oui
pour gagner de l'argent j'ai été
mannequin parallèlement j'ai suivi des
études comme tout le monde
quelles études aux études et à dire les
lycées jusqu'en terminale
et puis ensuite j'ai fait un pull
mannequin et puis cette chanson qui est
arrivé dans votre vie comme ça par
hasard plus souvent par hasard disons
que j'ai rencontré des personnes qui
sont mes producteurs laurent boutonnat
et jérôme dahan et compositeur et qui
m'ont proposé cette chanson j'ai écouté
souvent la chanson mais j'ai pas tout
compris vous êtes amoureuse de
l'infirmière c'est ça coûte et je peux
vous raconter un peu la chanson c'est
quelque chose qui me tient effectivement
un tracker ça peut arriver à beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont dans des centres
hospitaliers et qui n'ont finalement
pour
j'allais dire pour maman disons que ce
sont des personnes qui s'occupent de ces
enfants sont des infirmiers ou
infirmières et ses infirmières donne à
manger à ses enfants les bords de l'ill
heures fois un bisou avant de s'endormir
donc prennent la place des mamans donc
c'est une petite fille qui dit à sa
maman j'ai une infirmière
bon c'était un énorme succès vous allez
continuer ou c'est un coup comme l'on
dit non j'espère continuer là je vais
sortir un prochain 45 tours et puis
après on verra si ça marche je vous
signale que je le présentais de talent
nous avons ce soir dans la salle un des
grands grands présentateurs de la
télévision québécoise
c'est michel jasmin qui a présenté un
talk show pendant cinq ans à télé
métropole il une grande dit je vais
bavarder avec qui tout à l'heure et
comme vous avez habité pendant 13 ans là
bas vous pouvez les saluer car vous
savez que notre émission passe tous les
week-end le samedi soir à montréal et
dans tout le québec sur le canal 99 tvf
qu entre autres car cette émission passe
également dans tout le monde francophone
je vous souhaite une longue carrière
mademoiselle mylène farmer qui vient
pour la première fois à sont réalisés
[Musique]